when I'm on the ice I feel more lighter
I feel more faster I've feel like flying
all the time on the skates I feel strong
it gives me just more than a human
feeling you know
is among the highest altitude hockey
games you could possibly play you have
no air and you're suffocating while
exerting
I've seen goalies using pillows I mean
they'll use cricket equipment they used
anything they could
I have to take care of my family have to
think about so many things this one
thing he always used to say like even
though I didn't get to travel abroad but
you were getting to travel abroad so
many times I'm happy for that
the reality is India doesn't get behind
a team that they know is going to lose
they want to get behind the team that
will make them proud
I'm really proud that I am the part of
this history and I will try my best
they'll best that I sake India will
reach that heights in or which I have
dreamt about from so many years